c'est un autre classement qui est sorti
c'est la mannequin la mieux payée au
monde sait qui gisèle d'être au zéphyr
et jenna randall kendall jenner ouaga
tard kendall jenner vannes 2 millions de
dollars par an ouais ouais
elle est mannequin et la soeur de kim
kardashian de zaporijia gisele bündchen
moyens mais pas des masses d'ailleurs
disent tu vois et entends brasserie site
hagen numéro 3 chez pas qui c'est
adriana lima numéro quatrième et en
cinquième j j a dit koné messemba non
mais elle s'appelle vraiment juger et sa
soeur mais l'a dit nous sommes
classement aussi la wii jj hardy les
balades
il perd la balle à s'assumer la lime
d'accord vont pas très bien mon lit en
bois jj et bella merci